si le soir de la saint sylvestre le
couvre feu était fixé à 20 heures et le
nombre maximum d'adultes autorisés à se
rassembler été fixé à 6 plus de 2500
fêtards avaient décidé de se réunir dans
un hangar désaffecté à lieuron en
bretagne dans l'esprit des manifestants
la fête a pris le dessus sur le virus
ces lacunes est répartie gigantesque qui
est totalement illégal s'est déroulé
durant presque 72 heures si de nombreux
participants ont été verbalisés à la
sortie de l'événement un jeune homme
identifie comme étant l'un des
organisateurs de la fête est incarcéré
depuis lundi soir il reste jusqu'à dix
ans de prison
une sanction qui pour les participants
est totalement démesurée un mec de 22
ans qui n'a pas de casier risque 10 ans
de prison pour avoir fait danser des
gens le soir du nouvel an c'est du
délire et c'est très grave
cette jeune femme comme de nombreux
participants à cette rave party regrette
la mauvaise image que les gens ont de
leur mouvement et de leur passion des
sympathisants appellent à un
rassemblement à rennes demain pour faire
bouger les choses et que le jeune
organisateur présumé soit relaxé alors
dix ans de prison encourue pour
l'organisateur de la rave party normal
ou pas normal on adrien avec tout
amateur de rave party alors adressé une
première question à se poser
oui c'est que avec tous les teufeurs que
j'ai même la jeune fille la draft qui
était à qui était à la grosse fête la
voilà la grosse rave party camille elle
était chez elle avec le basque ça veut
dire vous faites des tofs de ouf
avec 2000 personnes vous mettez série je
vais vous coupez il faut pas mettre dans
le même panier
d'accord d'amis les jeunes et ça se voit
sa façon de parler et d'être dire je
t'emmerde et tout ça c'était quelque
chose a pas dire d'accord du coup tout
le monde nous a mis une étiquette tous
dans le même panier de c'est ça je suis
énervé ça fait un an
moi je suis pas sorti en neuf pour effet
depuis le confinement assez beau pour le
reste confiné je passe je me lève le
matin je vais travailler je rentre chez
moi je reste confinée cette fête le 31
moi je sais pas je n'ai pas été jeu
celle d'organisateur et beaucoup de son
système n'était pas pour cette fête
ouais j'suis d'accord que cette fête on
l'a puni ce merdier ans de prison pour
un homme un artiste en plus parce que
c'est des artistes il faut le savoir
bien chez moi mais c'est vrai qui a
voulu faire vivre un instant des gens de
toutes classes parce que dans ce milieu
là il n'ya pas d'étiquette c'est pas toi
tu es riche toi tu es noir toi ceci gens
mais on est tous pareils tous au même
niveau au train de danser autour d'un
feu il ya des chirurgiens les policiers
et père de famille vient de tout il ya
tout d'être toutes les fournir la
société oui il ya de tout juste adrien
petit bug vous en parler parce que
j'aime bien voilà le j'aime bien en tout
cas la façon de parler d'adrian francs
j'aime bien comment ils expliquaient les
chaudes c'est pas
peu d illuminer les mecs qui vont dans
les rave parties je vous dis c'est déjà
ça peut être des potes à nous c'est
toujours l'action dans la société civile
comme il a dit après c'est vrai qu'on
l'a dit ou condamnent toussaint cette
fête de 2500 personnes parce que
forcément voilà c'est c'est inadmissible
mais c'est vrai que là dix ans de prison
qui ce faisant penser à vos pieds de
manga est ce que vous trouvez que c'est
normal ou pas normal est ce que vous
trouvez que c'est normal reposer à
quelque chose que vous trouvez que c'est
normal et chez vous disons prison c'est
pas normal pas normal c'est juste est ce
que vous trouvez que c'est normal pour
vous adrien c'est disproportionné pas
possible regardez vous prenez un homme
qui va violer quelqu'un une fille une
petite fille ou même un garçon sans
angle pendant des années lui va se
prendre deux à trois heures cinq ans de
prison max pour avoir détruit la vie de
cet enfant d'ordonnancé mois par les
cires il faut savoir que dans le temps
le moral de cette jeune fille ou de ce
garçon va être détruit et lui va se
manger trois ans un mec qui a voulu
faire danser les gens vivre donné
redonner de l'espoir en 107 années 2020
qui était vraiment on va pas pour être
poli de la merde c'est dur pour vous à
quel âge hadrien g 24 ans ça a été dur
pour toi de 24 ans vice convives mais
bien sûr pour tous les jeunes mais poc
pour moi pour les personnes âgées pour
tout le monde rester comme ça chez soi
être interdit de faire ce semble surtout
quand on est jeune comme ça on a envie
de sortir on a envie de faire des aînés
et des jsl vous savez c'est pas question
de gènes capables n'y a pas autant il ya
aussi bien des vieux qui vont te que des
jeunes cc on est un mouvement libre on
est libre y'a pas de classe aujourd'hui
c'est votre travail
il est compliqué en ces temps de covin
tout le monde ah oui mais nous aussi des
fois on a envie un peu de se vider la
tête cholet d'aller danser juste danser
découvrir des gens découvrir d'autres
âmes parler discuter rencontrer du monde
et le lendemain on retombe dans notre
meilleur nom pendant une soirée dix ans
de prison pour une soirée je trouve ça
c'est c'est trop alors il ya maxime qui
dit oui
normal ils risquent dix ans non pas pour
avoir ces danses et des gens mais pour
avoir mis en garde bp
mais m e pour avoir mis en danger la vie
d'autrui et là et aurait pu créer un
cluster créé des massacres et des morts
en pleine pandémie
c'est hyper très bien je vois que
parfois il faut être référent et me
donner des sanctions qu'ils soient
référente et qui parle à tout le monde
alors atp la ratp
j'ai des photos la ratp des sardines
collés les uns les autres sans masque
personnes là c'est pas un crime le puy
du fou qui était ouvert 12 une personne
là c'est pas un crime les miss france
c'est par un king pourquoi
pour vous ils vont voir est pas si nous
ne rapporte pas d'argent
les salades riez pas donc du coup voilà
dix ans je pense que c'est pas c'est pas
complètement con ce que dit un agent
sera mais la main mais il a il a un
discours qui sien il ya besoin de gens
je suis sûr la joie plein de gens
rejoignent plein de téléspectateurs qui
hochent la tête et qui disent c'est vrai
que bon ils sont content reçues sur ses
rêves parti qui s'organisait mais il ya
plein de choses qui sont faites qui sont
faites pas ce que ça rapporte de
l'argent et et mine de rien on n'est pas
d'accord aussi là dessus quand on voit
des restaurateurs qui sont fermés et
quand on voit mine de rien c'est vrai
que les métros bondés on s'est toujours
posé la question c'est la grande
question que se pose plein de gens
depuis des semaines et des semaines les
trains vous avez parlé du puy du fou
c'est vrai que voilà bon hein et ça
s'est passé j'ai pas de bombe et georges
ont rejoint monsieur c'est normal
lorsque vous dites que dans le métro les
gens sont serrés comme des sardines
je suis totalement d'accord avec blue
c'est honteux mais c'est essentiel mais
important de se déplacer hors les rave
parties c'est pas essentiel à l'arrêter
route mettez vous dans la peau de cet
artiste qui s'est dit bon poser des
inférences résultat d'aujourd'hui sur le
faire mais comment vous pouvez prévoir
que 2500 personnes va débarquer moi je
dis que la police est en tort un petit
peu dans ce sens comme d'habitude il
débranche laissant monsieur vous étiez
au courant alors normalement la fête
c'est à la dernière minute on le sait
toujours à la dernière minute
les organisateurs eux mêmes mais pour
les gens qui attendent cette fête on le
sait qu'à la dernière minute et vous a
dit qu il y aurait une fête pour le
nouvel an lunaire est parti j'étais au
courant de nom n'hésitez pas à vous
rendre compte je comprends je comprends
ce que ce que dit mon collègue au bout
maxime pardon et je comprends ce que tu
dis les deux les deux ont raison absolue
la fête je comprends les artistes ont
besoin d'exprimer ça c'est normal après
dix ans c'est cher payé pour un gamin de
22 ans l'attaquant sur la famille qui
soit qu'il faut punir et qu'ils soient
réprimandés
moi j'aurais pu ni pour des tâches
d'intérêt c'est ça la république va
nettoyer les forêts va faire ça mais
pendant aussi le lourd quoi tu vois va
aider les personnes âgées ou malades
ducobu ça va être peut-être marquant un
tu vois dix ans ils risquent jusqu'à 10
ans dahmani qui dépendent du rni risque
nicolas pernikoff ce que je voulais dire
à adrien d'ailleurs c'est plutôt un
discours intelligent mais il est
indéfendable
donc effectivement c'est que les
branches les plus pourris sont
défendables
non mais c'est pas ça rien là où vous
avez raison c'est qu'effectivement un
homme qui a un casier vierge qui veut un
enfant c'est de prendre 4 50 tonnes avec
une remise de peine
donc on peut pas comparer ce ce fou
furieux parce que ça vous sur jeudi la
nouvelle finir en rythme des furieux un
gentil fou furieux 410 en moi ou il
pourrait avoir une sanction intérêt
collectif et faire quelque chose là
c'est ce que je pense
oui mais de toute façon il prendra pas
dix ans on le sait en revanche il mérite
une peine assez lourde pourquoi vous
compariez avec la ratp ça n'a rien à
voir
la ratp c'est un passage où ils les gens
sont masquées je suis désolé en revanche
dans les rave parties
les mecs ils sont et définit son pendant
4 5 heures en train de se cracher à la
gueule en dansant et tous avoir atteint
6 à 10 ans et une éthique et de singes
femelles étaient présents lors du sud au
final que les gens se crache dessus
il y avait des masques à disposition du
magnifique exposition tout et est à deux
matches qu'on a vu n'y a pas de match
lorsque c'est le média le média ne
montrera jamais quelque chose de positif
du parti libre maintenant nous on ne
sera jamais bien correctement mises en
avant
ça serait ce jour le mal pour le mal
pour le mal c'est comme ça c'est le
monde d'aujourd'hui c'est les médias les
chiffres la drire vous faites du secours
et des sous sur la misère des gens sur
la misère du monde aujourd'hui à l'heure
actuelle je suis d'accord avec général à
les médias en général mais désolé je
suis à madrid joue dans ce que tu veux
dire adrien on cherche on cherche le
sensationnalisme on va vraiment y aller
et je trouve qu'à adrien dans ce que tu
dis t'as pas complètement tort je te
rejoins c'est vrai que on va jamais
montré des jeunes il faut une soirée
sympa avec des masses et on va dire
regardez ils sont magnifiques on va
toujours chercher les mecs qui foutent
la merde où les mecs vous dessinez oui
mesdames on essaie de chercher du
sensationnalisme il a alors que la cades
rien oui il a fait des fêtes avec
d'époque où il était avec des basses où
il avait pris toutes les précautions
nécessaires
donc à un moment c'est vrai que dans ce
qui dit où on montre que le négatif
alors moi je veux bien qu'il ya un truc
aussi qui peuvent déranger c'est que les
jeunes on a l'impression si qui font que
des conneries au nord il ya plein de
jeunes qui respecte le confinement comme
il a dit oui ça fait un an
il a respecté le truc ya jamie j'ai
jamais vu un un sujet sur un jeune qui
respectait le confinement qui faisait
ses trucs qui fermait sa gueule qui
resté chez lui qui disait bah écoute
voilà j'ai essayé de faire le maximum
pour aussi aidé la société hepalink
mobile de rien tirer les ont quand même
dans un moment oui mais non pas de
s'appeler autrement non mais je dis
juste je dis juste qu'il ya mais surtout
ce câble sat ils apprendront ce qu'ils
n'ont pas dit comment là je suis
complètement d'accord avec adrien est ce
que je trouve terrible c'est que les
médias et les policiers
quelque part c'est terrible il de dire
ça mais ça les arrange parce que non
c'est les marginaux de la société s'est
envolé mort qui vient sceller marginaux
de la société il profite du fait qu'ils
aient des drogues est prouvé il montre
que le mauvais côté des teufs et il juge
les te faire les en profite pour juger
des tôles et disons prison par là
quelqu'un qui organise une teuf et comme
il dit qu'il s'agisse de redonner de
l'espoir des sourires etc
c'est pas son problème si personne ne
respectez les distances à sion et c'est
pas le problème de l'organisateur
quelque part et il ne s'attendait pas à
voir 2500 personnes on va voir en vrai
c'était spectateurs et on passera la
dernière partie dans une rivière
et regardez regardez disant regardez
regardez en dix ans de prison pour
l'organisateur de la répartie 55 % des
gens trouvent que c'est normal ça n'a
rien à voir avec ce qu'on a sur ce
plateau adrien testud répond aux
téléspectateurs parce que parce que ça
prouve aussi la prise de conscience d'un
téléspectateur sur la gravité ouais
voilà de ce qu'on vit sur la gravité de
ces fêtes oui est ce que je peux leur
quelque chose que j'ai écrit bien sûr
haïti alors toute notre vie n'est qu'une
suite de légende
le livre ses crimes et le destin lui
nous attend seuls les poissons morts
suivent le courant d'autres vont marquer
les mémoires
et puis les autres dans l'oubli mais
n'oublions pas que nous sommes venus sur
terre en hommes libres libres de
cultiver libre d'être différent libre de
crier dans les rues libre d'aimer libre
d'être différent la simple la simple et
bonne raison la liberté de vivre mais ne
perd pas ton temps toi mon frère a
regardé en arrière tu sais très bien tu
n'iras pas par là où sans doute on y
retourne plus l'humain avance et plus
les cycles se répète mais en plus
moderne
après tout la vie est aussi un cycle et
tout cycle a une fin le pouvoir a
toujours voulu intéressé l'homme
c'est une forme naturelle chez les
animaux mais si au fond de toi mon frère
ou ma soeur est encore une flamme
allumée et bien allume celle de ton
voisin et fait revivre la solidarité la
lumière et l'espoir afin de ne pas
devenir un petit poisson 2 millions
voilà 80 millions de personnes
contaminées deux millions de morts c'est
tout on parle pas d'une gastro entérite
on part d'une pandémie
ce soir c'est tout moi séjour et
personnes âgées aujourd'hui meurt
beaucoup pourquoi parce qu'ils n'ont pas
de famille qu'ils ne peuvent voir
personne syndrome de glissement on se
laisse mourir et premièrement et on a
changé les choses en réponse à ça rentre
dans les chiffres kobe tu dresses à
adrien
adrian 7 5% c'est le fret cette fête
même toi même toit cette fête tu dis que
tu là cela fonctionne pas non non pas
cette polémique on savait par téléphone
ce mal se faire voir on savait qu'on
allait crie au loup on savait qu'on
allait se faire taper sur les doigts
tout simplement
il aurait dû comme la police a toujours
fait dans plusieurs rêves où j'ai été
quand ils sont pas d'accord qu'on n'a
pas une autorisation terrain que ça soit
par un agriculteur ou autres ils
viennent il débranche ils sont ils
embarquent les quais sont terminées
pourquoi il
ils n'ont pas fait sur cette fête là
pour question de simplement merci à yves
nicolas riz juste une question qu'a
lancé vous d'aider des personnes dans
les ehpad qui peuvent pas voir leur
famille depuis un an vous pensez que
parce qu'elles sont pas jeunes c'est pas
la même vie qu'ils ont ou c'est pas pire
je vous mettez là je parlais des
chiffres n'ont mis d'accord non mais
c'est malheureux mais les morts on les
compte les morts
les personnes arrivées à des mots rares
on habite son nom vous dit les jeunes
sont jeunes ils ont besoin de vivre ils
ont besoin de faire la vie va être de se
voir de s'aimer tâche est d'accord vous
dit que pensez vous dans les ehpad des
gens comme ça que je prends de l'église
et à leurs familles depuis un an
mais après c'est le problème de la
famille s'ils savent pas s'occuper de
leurs parents et qui la met en maison
dont ils n'ont pas le droit puis un
moment il ya des va voir on va voir on
en est du sondage merci
regardez 55% normal 45% bernard mal donc
voilà c'est sévère mais les gens disent
que plus d'un sur deux normes disent que
c'est normal merci en tout cas de rien
d'avoir exposé ton point de vue